helping and sharing local nonprofit safe
nests is teaching life skills to
survivors of domestic and sexual
violence and you can help them gain
independence and enjoy a nice cup of
coffee and know you're making a
difference mary jane balieza live this
morning to talk about safe nest coffee
mary jane good morning to you
it's really trying to push survivors to
have a sense of financial freedom all
while making a paycheck and for a good
cause i have two survivors with me right
now tyresha and charmaine who are both
packaging up the coffee you can see
they're busy here at work and charmaine
thanks so much for joining us early this
morning i do want to ask you you know
what does this program mean for you
this program means for me the hope
for financial stability and independence
just for me and my kids to
know that we can and move on and we can
do it that's perfect and of course
tyrese thank you so much for waking up
with us early as well tell me what does
this program mean for you and what are
you learning it's a stepping stone and
like it's for my own business so like i
can have
sales fulfillment and marketing to know
things to step up higher to my
you know stepping stone that's exciting
of course opening up a business is such
a great goal to look forward to thank
you so much and also joining me is liz
ortenberger she's safe and as ceo and
you know this is such a great way for
you guys to really teach them financial
freedom independence but also a great
cause as well for the community to help
out yeah absolutely you know survivors
are in strong incredibly amazing women
and men that come to us and what they
need is they need help and support just
energizing that skill set in a way that
it can be most influential in their
financial future and that's what this
program does it takes survivors and
gives them an opportunity so that the
future looks brighter than the past that
is perfect liz thank you so much i mean
such a great cause really helping out
the community and the survivors as well
i know that it smelled great earlier
with the coffee brewing and definitely a
great way to really help out the
community here reporting live mary jane
balleza live local now